[Inaudible] so, uh, I mean, looking at these pictures,
especially one picture that I found before, before when I knew we should beat.
Um, and th this is, this is a, this is a bit look at that.
It's like you're flying. Yeah. Yeah. My first thought was
don't you ever hurt yourself?
Um, yes, actually, um, a year ago I ruptured my Achilles tendon.
Uh three-quarters of it. Um, it's quite a story. Um, I was in Italy, Sicily,
and I met Lenny Kravitz and Lenny was like, Oh,
I would like to dedicate this song to McKayla, to Prince. And I was like,
Oh my God, it's Lenny Kravitz. And then, so, um,
I'm a clumsy person as well. So I was like, okay, let me be smart about this.
I'm going to take my heels off and go and sit next to him on stage.
And so I sit like, uh, at the bench underneath the stage,
I'm just looking at him like, Oh, I love you so much. And then, um,
I get off the seat and then I, uh, like fall into a big dip.
Cause it was at a old temple and old temples are unfortunately uneven.
And I knew right away. I was like, Oh, I ruptured my Achilles.
I went to my agent. I said, I have to go to the hospital.
I ruptured my Achilles.
Doing that. You did it.
I know. I know. I know. And.
Exactly. Yeah. Um, and you were child number 27?
Uh, no pick ILO. Yeah. Child number 27.
Well, I was number 27 and my original name is Ms. Vinci.
And the thing is I had be Lego.
I was born with the skin condition and in West Africa they thought because of my
gender, which is the white it's the white spots. Yeah.
It was more pronounced when I was younger because I was very malnourished. Um,
after losing both my parents, my uncle brought me to the orphanage.
The orphanage they ranked us from one is a favorite child.
Number 27 is the least favorite. And because of my spots,
they called me the devil child, the devil child. Yeah.
They thought anything that happened,
anything that was wrong was my fault that I caused it to happen. If it was,
if you didn't get enough crops, if you, if the rain didn't come that year,
if it was my fault, because it was very spiritual. And you would think that,
you know, all these children we've lost our families.
You would think these women that were taking care of us would show us love and
nurture us and care for us. But instead they just treat,
it treated me like the devil shop.
And then my best friend who was number 26 because she was left-handed and she
didn't choose to be born. Left-handed.
Being ranked so low. Uh, what, what,
what did that lead to, I mean, did you.
Did you have to, did you get the same food as the elders or did you know?
I got smaller portion of food. I got the last choice of the clothing pile.
I was, yeah. They, I remember they told me who would want,
who adopted the devil's child? I wasn't going to get adopted,
but luckily enough, because my best friend had the exact same name. My mom,
my mom now she was looking online and she said,
and she called the agency and she said, Oh, I'd like to adopt them venti.
And they said, well, which one? Lindsey, duh, duh. But, um,
and so then they, my mom realized there's another Mabenti. They were like, yeah,
we have to. And they explained that nobody wanted me because of my spots.
They didn't, they thought, you know, to have issues and insecurity.
So they didn't want to deal with that. But then my mom was like,
I will take her. Okay.
She's American.
When did you first discover ballet?
Because in wa war-torn in Sierra Layola there wasn't much ballet wasn't there?
No ballet all, I mean, of course it's a, it's a very cultural,
it's a lot of music, a lot of dancing, different things,
but I never saw ballet before.
And so this magazine I found in Sierra Leone,
it was 10 years after this magazine was published.
And on the cover was a ballerina. Her name is Maggie MESAC.
It took us maybe 12 to 15 years to find out who she was.
But I saw, I saw this person, but it could have been a tennis player.
It could have been anybody.
Was she looked happy and as the child in the orphanage and the orphanage. Yeah.
And I was four years old. And so in this time it wasn't the two, two,
it wasn't this. I mean, it was cool. Like, she was very pretty,
but she looks so happy and I wanted to know what that felt like. So I thought,
okay, I'm going to be exactly like her in this way. I would be happy to.
And do you keep that with you? Yeah,
I ripped the cover off and it's pretty gross, but, um, I put it in my underwear.
Um, cause I was the only place I could put it. And when I got adopted,
I tried to explain to my mom why my adopted mom,
why I was looking through her luggage. So I assumed, okay,
American mothers are going to have everything, right. You're 22, your Tiara,
your point shoes is it's automatic. But so it was looking through everything.
And then the only way I could explain to her,
what I was looking for was show her that picture,
the most precious thing that I had just to give it to her. And she understood.
Right.
Wow. So then she wanted to help you. Yeah. And she coming would dance.
Uh, but before that, I mean, you,
you grew up in a very different part of the world and you come with your
now sister. Um, and you, you, you, you come to,
to us. W w can you remember your first impression?
Can you remember that? W what, what that was like.
I mean, going to the grocery store for the first time was in credible,
I had never seen that was my,
I think my favorite part was the fact that in the orphanage,
we didn't have food.
We didn't have a lot of food in the food that we got was not very good at all.
It was mostly rice or beans, but when I went to Subaru,
my favorite thing that I grabbed, the first thing was grapes.
I had never tasted anything like that. It was absolutely amazing. And also,
I didn't know that you had to pay for it. So I just was like.
But, um, yeah, it was, it was a, of a shock. And.
Then also, um, like my family were quite big.
There are nine of us adopted six from West Africa,
two from the Philippines and one from the States.
And the reason why we got adopted is because Michael,
my three of my brothers had HIV and AIDS. And so Michael, before he passed away,
he begged my parents to adopt a child from West Africa. So in his honor,
that's what they did. But, uh, to go into a place where, yeah,
Mikayla, Mia, Mario were all M's. Um,
but to go into a place where all of a sudden, everybody loves you. You're,
you're wondering why, but I, I, I thought I was this monster.
Why would you think, why would you love me?
Because I look hor I thought I looked like a monster because of what they
told me, but it was amazing the amount of love and it was,
and the, the things that my mom would make us the amount of food that, yeah.
I felt like.
Were you able to receive that kind of love from the start? Or was it difficult,
a difficult transition for you?
It was very difficult. It took me some time, because as a child,
because of the PTSD, I thought I was still in Sierra Leone.
So every single time I'd go to bed, I would be scared to wake up and be back.
On you. You've, you've experienced some terrible things. Seen a lot of.
Yeah. And so I would be so scared to fall asleep. And, um,
and when I would fall asleep,
I'd relive the nightmares that I had in Sierra Leone constantly every single
night.
And it took me a few years to finally believe I was in the States that I wasn't
gonna wake up and be back in the orphanage. Can you still have nightmares? Yeah.
Um, I was diagnosed officially almost two years ago with BTFC, uh,
to the point where I was so dissociated with, um,
what I was doing that I just was on autopilot. Wasn't sleeping at night.
I was terrified. Um, I was very hypersensitive, but I went to S uh,
to a therapist and started EMDR, which is, um, rapid eye movement.
And it is incredible. It's not just that. I just, I, I, I,
I went to a therapist. I talked about my problems.
I didn't pretend that I didn't have this issue.
I finally gave myself a chance to, to heal. And that was, uh,
the biggest achievement I think I've accomplished. So that's helped. Yeah,
definitely.
Um, becoming a dancer,
ballet, a soloist, uh, as you are,
it's not an easy way. I mean, even though you have the support from,
from home, it's a very, this is a very white art form.
Yeah. Unfortunately, and I know you made a point of that. Um,
uh, in what way has that been difficult for you?
Well, the thing is when you see somebody on TV and they look like you,
you think you can accomplish something. I didn't see that.
So I was very worried and I did have a few people,
like there is Heidi Cruz from Pennsylvania ballet who was very supportive.
And especially when, um, I was getting ready to do this role, I was so excited.
Everybody knows a Nutcracker, right? Yeah. And I was getting ready to do Maria.
I was rehearsing and rehearsing. And then I overheard my teacher saying, Oh,
she's not going to do, because America's already for black Marie.
I was a little child. I was so excited to achieve this, um, yeah.
To be the lead in the Nutcracker. And this is when I started to realize, Oh,
this is going to be so hard. And of course, sometimes I was like, okay,
this is just not worth it.
I there's nobody else out there like me there's there was like maybe five,
five principle dancers that I knew that were African-American.
And then I saw everybody else and I was like, okay, is this really worth it?
Is it really worth feeling like I don't belong all the time that I have to
not eat because I need to be just as skinny as those other girls that, you know,
I was constantly discriminated against because of the fact that I was a certain
color. And it wasn't just that in ballet, it was also my outside life as well.
So when I went to go and do something that I love so much,
I was discriminated against because of it. It was. Yeah. But also,
I like to prove people wrong, so try to prove them wrong.
[Inaudible].
Are you, um, at, at this time,
when you overheard them saying that you couldn't do the lead part in the
Nutcracker. Yeah. And it's, and that was just the beginning.
That was.
Yeah. I do have support from the government or.
My parents. And it's a, the arts is such a beautiful thing.
It's so historical that, and it's so expensive to do something so incredible.
And to, to, especially for children like me, my family, the arts has helped,
like it has saved us. It has helped us find a way to express ourselves.
My sisters are singers, um, uh, pianos, uh,
she can play the oboe art. If we didn't have that,
I don't know how we would be or who we would be right now. Do you,
do you feel like you've passed the point of being, um,
the black ballet dancer and just become this super amazing
ballet dancer? Is that even something you're striving for it?
Yes. I'm because the thing is, I talk about,
I'm like saying I'm a black ballet dancer, ballerina. You don't doctor,
doesn't say I'm a black doctor pilot. Yeah.
And you have to constantly have to say this because there aren't black
ballerinas and these children, like they're saying, Oh,
we want to make the companies more diverse.
But if you're discriminating children who are different. Yeah.
How are you going to make anything different within the company.
Even, even the clothes for a ballerina made for.
Yes, exactly. But now I just helped, um, a brand called Gaynor.
Minden is a point shoe brand, also freed London as well,
came out with Brown point shoes. So in 2017,
gainer Midian came out with the very first pair of Brown point shoes.
I now wear Brown point shoes on stage and Brown tights as well.
And I feel like myself, I, it's not two different people.
I just always felt like, like I couldn't stand. Like,
I couldn't be proud of dancing on stage. I couldn't,
I wasn't a hundred percent there.
You've you've, uh, you've also done, uh, performed in a video by Beyonce.
So that was pretty cool too. That's very cool.
[inaudible] so I guess that was nice.
And also Madonna is going to do a film about.
Yeah. She's directing my life story my little life, but yeah, my life.
Um, I would say,
first of all, I would say lucky her, uh, project,
but where are you a fan? Where are you a Madonna fan?
I mean, yeah. I've had, uh, not to put this in a way,
but I have a lot of gay friends and that's why I knew about Madonna and her
music. And, but when I met Madonna, it wasn't,
she is so incredible. And so like, she does her,
she does it her way. And that inspired me to do my way,
the way I want to do it the way. Yeah. Not the way everybody else is doing.
I want to be able to leave a Mark. And that is what she's doing. And she's so,
I mean, she is so intelligent and just so like, yeah,
she doesn't take from anybody.
But I believe this is survey. That could be a successful,
they took all your own way and follow not a data.
If a father other this value, we talk about Norway. [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
No, no, no, no. But I say to the suites, I come 95 there. And I say,
if you follow Norway, we never beat SIM. We are always number two. And this,
I think it's in every single follow your dreams. Exactly what you're like.
It doesn't matter what it's a good carpenter has also a good life also.
And this is what I prefer for my life
that I live in a three. And you live in a treatment, you live in a treatment,
you live in a dream, you have to harvest life from us,
but the people fight the cancer, your path.
This is I think the secret of a good life doing it your way.
It doesn't matter how successful, but do you have to follow?
This is what your life.
I think, uh, with those words, uh,
I think we should let you take the stage because your band is waiting for you.
Oh yes. Thank you so much. Thank you.
[inaudible].
Thank you so much for sharing your story here before you do it with Madonna.
I really appreciate that. And, uh, and good luck with everything.
Thank you so much.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.